[Music]
Hello friends and welcome to I'd like to
know our question and answer program
here at some TV and secrets unsealed and
we are so very very glad that you choose
to join us for this power packed 30
minutes I am CA Murray and I'm in the
company of Pastor David Salazar and
Pastor Steven bour and we are here to
answer your bible-based questions from
the word of God let me give you the
contact information right away it is
tvom tv.org that is TV at susum as in
Mary
tv.org should you have a Biblical
question write to that send that in and
we will get the answer to you just as
quickly as we possibly can takes us a
little while to get through all of these
questions so we make you the promise
that we will get to your question sooner
or later perhaps sooner than later and
we will get you the answer from the word
of God if indeed an answer can be found
we will find it and get it to you
because we want to help you in your
spiritual walk with the Lord and we like
to study the word of God so it's a
win-win sit situation for you and for us
too Pastor boy we want to get right into
our our list of questions for today so
would you lead us in prayer please
before we launch out with questions
certainly Father in heaven we come
before your awesome throne and we come
boldly because we come in the name of
Jesus father you we have so many
questions questions that uh many of
which we don't have answers for but you
have all of the answers and uh if we're
in touch with you we'll be able to find
many of the answers to the questions
that are sent to us I ask Lord that you
will Enlighten our minds give us Clarity
of thought give us uh the ability to
express our thoughts clearly amen that
those who are watching this program
might be blessed that their spiritual
life might be edified and we thank you
Lord for the privilege of prayer and
know that you have heard and answered
this prayer because we ask it in Jesus
name name amen amen and amen one of the
things that I've always found
interesting when I began to do this
program with pastor bour and then later
with pastor solidar we don't study the
questions together we don't go in a room
and close the door and hash out an
answer we study independently we have
three sets of questions and we study
independently and we find when we come
together the spirit of God has moved and
worked we have many times the same text
we certainly have the same mindset and
the same thoughts to these questions so
that lets me know that the spirit is
working and I like that that that makes
me very comfortable in in doing that so
Pastor boy we put the burden on you if
you would read our first question for
today okay this is a very simple
question it has come up before and uh
I'm not sure that we have a definitive
answer although I suspect that we do um
the question is this it comes from
Janelle uh location not
identified I would like to know what
will happen to our pets during the time
of persecution and will our pets be on
the new Earth that God has created
somehow I get the impression that this
is a question that is formulated by a
younger viewer of our program because uh
kids get very much attached even more
attached to a pets than uh some of of us
older folks uh so do we have any light
on that well you know the The Book of
Romans the Apostle Paul speaks in
chapter 8 and I'll just read verses um
21 and 22 and sort of gives the I'll
read it and then I'll sort of explain or
or share what what the word of God is
saying and it says because the creature
itself also shall be delivered from the
bondage of corruption into the Glorious
Liberty of the children of God for we
know that the whole creation granth and
travaileth in pain pain together until
now so the Bible and this is one verse
but there's other verses that sort of
explain that the creation the creatures
the
animals are travailing I will they
they're suffering because of sin and
they in a sense they they want they
grown for for liberty for for to get rid
of this experience of of of sin the
consequence of sin so God is aware that
every single thing that he created that
was perfect because of sin it became
corrupt and is is in
suffering uh now having said
that you know it's important that we
understand that Christ came to save man
and
Mankind we don't really have any
evidence from the word of God that he
came to save anything but the lives of
of of human beings and yes the extension
of creation that was made to be under
the control or the subject or under
subjection to men it's it's it's really
a responsibility but it is not Christ's
primary reason or is not the reason of
Christ coming to this earth it was not
to save the creation itself of the
animals and the elements but to save us
who were made in the image of God and uh
I think that's you know the most
important thing and I think there's also
you know another uh I think a book that
you mentioned Pastor B you know that
maybe can help Enlighten some of these
for our viewers yeah there's a book that
is produced by Steve walberg's uh
Ministry um White Horse media and I
don't know if we carry it here or not
but you can get it from him uh I think
the title is will my pet be in
heaven and honestly I haven't read the
book but the title of the book is very
interesting and I'm sure that he has
some very very interesting thoughts in
the book um you know our
become members of the family uh I
remember Steve our son had a dog were
you here when Dashers was here oh very
much so yeah uh we had a dog his name
was Dashers he was a border colag and we
l that dog as much as we loved any
member of the family uh and when the dog
got sick deathly sick we gathered over
at Danny lot's house you know as he was
about to die and I mean uh my son you
know who who's a tough guy you know he
cried just Bunches of tears right and we
all did right because because they
become members of the family yeah um but
having said that I Has Not Seen Nor Ear
heard uh what God has prepared for those
who love him right not even entered into
their
imagination so you know let's say that D
Dashers isn't going to be in heaven
there's going to be uh mascots that are
uh just as uh captivating uh or even
more so right than the ones we had on
Earth uh so you know basically there's I
I don't think that God is going to
resurrect every single animal and you
know is God going to protect the animals
during the time of trouble which is part
of the question well you know there
there are millions of animals that are
dying every day of of starvation
different places of the world so god
holds moral beings accountable right
dogs are not accountable in the Judgment
there you go I mean they're not
accountable because a dog bit you in the
leg you know God is going to punish them
for that because they're not moral
beings but we get attached to them yeah
um 1 Timothy
1:15 Paul says um Christ came to save
Sinners uh and that uh leads into your
last point he came to save sinners it
sounds almost cruel but it is true that
Christ didn't go to the Cross to save
your pet you know he did not right he he
he went to the Cross to save you now
suffice it to say whatever is in heaven
is going to be better than what is here
so you're not going to lose out on
anything you know you get to pet a a
lion or an elephant or you know whatever
so you you may not have Pho but you're
going to have something else and it's
going to be better than what you had
right so we look forward to to that
which is better and that's about as
close as we can come uh you know that
it's going to be better whatever you
have now Heaven is going to be better
and praise the Lord for that amen amen
and God takes care of animals I mean he
sees even this pharoh you know this
molish bird he takes care of that so he
we know that he cares But ultimately the
plan of Sal salvation or Redemption is
for mankind and not animals themselves
Al righty uh Pastor B would you take
this next question from uh repel I'm
looking at r e p l l again no location
and we want to encourage you if you will
it is not too much bother let us know
where you're writing from because it
helps us to know uh where we are being
consumed and uh what you're doing so let
us know where you are and add that
location if you
will okay uh very simple short question
I have people ask me this question would
love to know know what Jesus did for the
18 years that are
missing uh of his life record in the
Bible so the question is what
information do we have of the 18 years
where the Bible is silent between the
time that he was 12 years old and
visited the temple for the first time
and when he was baptized and began his
ministry well you know in Luke Chapter 2
there you go thank
you connecting there see we already knew
you were going to go
there um you know well we in that you
know as mentioned Pastor when he came
for the first time not the first time
because he came as a baby but you know
uh to be presented in the temple but
when he came when he had risen and he
was 12 years of age he came into the
temple and we know the story that's the
whole chapter 2 basically tells the
story there uh in the latter part of the
chapter but he I want to emphasize what
he said from verse 49
till
52 when he met the parents after three
days that they had been looking for him
he said unto them how is it that you
sought me was he not that I must be
about my father's business and then you
know he's telling them he is now
understanding his mission his you know
what he came to Earth for now verse 50
and 52 through 52 reads and they
understood not the same which he spake
unto them and he went down with them and
came to Nazareth and was subject unto
them but his mother kept all these
things in her heart and Jesus increased
in wisdom and stature and in favor with
God and men so just to sort of summarize
and I know you have more things to say
but we see that Christ understood his
mission now at that age but he chose to
submit and be subject to the parents to
the early parents for the remaining of
the time time until the Lord was to you
know you know the time of his appearing
needed to come and that was going to be
also fulfillment of Prophecy so for 18
years Christ just was subject to the
parents he helped them as a citizen as a
son as a friend financially he helped
his his early Father Joseph in the role
of carpentry so he was a worker with his
hands and he helped their Community as a
man you know as as a example of a of
someone who is good with a
family you know I might recommend uh
this uh person uh re
repel uh to get the LG white CD
ROM um there uh look up the word
Christ and uh there's going to be a
submenu under that and it has the stages
of Christ life and uh there's a section
at the very beginning of the list that
says uh his
childhood and uh there you have from the
spirit of Prophecy all kinds of
interesting details about those 18 years
you know one thing she says that he was
a
meticulous Carpenter MH very very
careful Carpenter she says also that the
that the kids in the neighborhood enjoy
being with him and they never gave in to
their peer pressure uh so there's a lot
of interesting details that she gives
there about this period of his life uh
which are not explicitly there in the
Bible but in principle they are based on
the text that you read from the Gospel
of Luke there you have the principle
right and then she adds several things
that go along with the principle yeah I
was going to to mention that I just
finished writing a sermon on this
section two o'clock this morning I went
to bed I put the pen down wow and I
dealt with uh many of alen white
statements about what happened during
those 18 years when he came out of the
the temple uh at age 12 that was a line
of demarcation he had figured out what
his mission was he figured out what
God's mission was and what how he
figured into it he elen says he looked
around he was like he's putting together
pieces of a puzzle and when he came out
and and and Mary sort of chastised we've
been looking for you we're sorry we've
been Sorrowing he he told her three
things one I know God's Mission I know
how I fit into that mission I know
Joseph is not my father I know God is so
he drew a line and then he stepped back
and for the next 18 years he just became
a good citizen but Ellen White says this
the kids in the neighborhood like to be
around him but even sometimes they got
exasperated with him because they wanted
him to cut up like they were cutting up
and he never did you know like you're
too straight lace you kind of approved
you just you know fool around a little
bit and she says he was unflappable you
couldn't you couldn't flatter him into
sin you couldn't coer him into sin he
was just straight up but even his
brothers same thing mhm be like us why
do you have to be so good all the time
why do you have to be so perfect just
hang out be like us you you you're
you're too singular you're too straight
lace so he was he was catching heat from
his brothers from some of the kids and
even Mary who saw what a wonderful child
he W he was wanted him to come under the
tutelage of some of the Pharisees and
that was not God's plan so she even
leaned on a little bit to use a term to
try to get him to to to follow you go
with the crowd just you know go with
that but he couldn't do that so El says
he spent a lot of time in nature by
himself some of his most joyous moments
were spent in nature understanding
because when he got around people there
was always this press to conform and he
was not going to conform by thought or
by deed so those 18 years were stressful
years they were not Carefree years but
he he was firm he was straight up he
stood for the Lord even during those
times when the Bible does not give us a
lot of insight yep but the spirit bravy
gives us a lot of you know if you go to
the CD Ram you're going to find that
section of the his childhood uh lots of
little intricate in interesting details
amen yeah good question repel uh hope
we're pronouncing that correctly and um
thank you for for uh sending in your
question we got time I think to slip in
one more more this is dear Pastor Boris
addressed to you but of course we this
is from Jack again uh we don't know
where it's coming from is it within the
principle of the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy to pay former Church employees
from tithe funds he has an example a
denominational worker retires and
immediately enters into elective
politics or openly becomes gay does this
person retain the right to receive TI
funds you know uh I hope that this is
just a hypothetical case yeah because
because you know that would be uh
calamitous uh to have someone you know
uh get uh paid from the tithe and uh and
then to uh get involved in the political
system of the United States or wherever
and becoming gay um you know
what I might say is that an
individual that receives um retirement
funds is getting the retirements funds
based on previous
service right so in other words uh the
way it works now is that certain amount
of money is placed into the stock market
and the the employee can match it uh so
so basically when they retire they're
receiving uh
money from what was put in the stock
market for the service that they
rendered before right so they're not
getting paid from that point on they're
getting paid for the service that they
rendered before yeah before the person
was gay if or before the person entered
politics I know two oh three that
entered politics they went from the
pulpit to politics um to get invested I
think you have to work 15 years Pastor
or so I think and and two of them I know
crossed the 15year threshold the other
one did not um but the state says you
cannot take money for retirement for a
person and then not give it to them
right regardless of what you know they
turn out to be down the road right um so
these three persons who are in politics
were receiving uh sustentation from from
the church yeah bottom line is that
they're not being they're not being paid
tithe money from the point that they're
retired on because the way the system
works at least in North America now is
that the conference uh you know the the
conference puts a certain percentage
right into an account on this in the
stock market and then the employee can
match a certain percentage and then the
money is placed while you're active it's
placed into that fund and when you
retire you draw on the fund but they're
not getting paid from the tithe from
that point on right right yeah now you
know the he asks the question or he
actually ends the question with this his
understanding that a ministerial calling
uh is a lifelong calling um it it should
be that way it should be a being you
know part of ministry should be a first
of all a calling of the Lord and it
should be a lifelong commitment to the
Lord but we know examples in the Bible
uh in the of the Apostles also that
there are people who deviate from the
faith and you know even though they had
a great experience in Ministry they s go
sideways so we don't have the ability to
control anybody at the end of the day
it's the choice so ultimately I think
that we need to um uh encourage those
that are in Ministry to remain faithful
to the Lord and to continue in that
lifelong call but if they deviate if
they go in politics or they change their
moral compass and and you know they do
these kind of things we know that they
ultimately the results up to the Lord
and He will give them according to their
to their deeds you know to the decisions
they they're lost is their loss we are
not to look into these situations and
cases and sort of dwell on them because
you know you get discourage and you
start thinking you know what's going on
with the funds and the tiing and all
these things and I think this is a a
dangerous way of approaching these
scenarios we have to be uh reminded that
the Lord is uh the one that ultimately
uh will bring a reward to each one and
so uh we got to encourage the faithful
and those that are in the ministry to
remain faithful to the ministry and to
the Lord yeah I need to clarify
something um couple of decades ago uh
the denomination in North America I
can't speak about other parts in the
world um the the denominate decided to
develop a new uh sustentation system
retirement and those of us who for
example if I had 20 years of service up
to that point they gave you a lump sum
uh which would have been your retirement
for those 20 years and then from that
point on they uh until your retirement
they placed a certain amount of money
into the stock market so um I am
receiving sustentation from the
nomination for the 20 years of service
but from that point on uh you know they
would put a certain amount into the
stock market and I would invest a
percentage and uh and so I'm drawing
from two places but workers now draw
only from that which they earned when
they were in active service so that's
the new retirement system I I thought
that I needed to clarify that because
some workers that work uh I think you
had to work a certain number of years
and then you would get a lump sum based
on the number of years and then after
that you know till you retired a certain
amount to the stock market so but the
system now is that workers who retire uh
they're drawing totally under 401K
exactly and it's not necessarily the the
tithe money going to them and that's one
thing that's important to to clarify for
right but again it may be different in
other parts of the world and if that was
the case you know if there was a system
where they were under the tie directly
um you know it's up to the local
conferences to decide what it should be
done you know um obviously a person that
goes against the word of God should be
caught from the the the you know the
credentials and all those things from
the ministry yeah and it's hard Peg to
the number of years you worked so that
if you stop working there's a ceiling
there yeah uh it doesn't go on forever
so right uh you're not being actively
drawing from the from the the monies of
the of the church so you know the church
looks for itself it is very very jealous
towards stewardship and being good
stewards of the monies that people send
in particularly tithe monies uh very
very the church does a good job I I feel
in dealing with uh uh those things and
maybe one last point in this regard that
we have to remember is that the system
the organization of the church is also
under the jurisdiction or under the
authority of the legal systems of the
world and so therefore there are some
legal aspects that will require them to
pay retirement or that kind of thing so
it's also important that we understand
that there's some limits to what they
could do very true and there's legal uh
connections or responsibilities that
they must fulfill so that's why it's
best not to try to look into these
situations that are complicated you know
and and are really uh difficult to to
completely understand or explain yeah
yeah you know when you when you're a
self-supporting Ministry you have 501c3
status uh to be able to receive
donations and you know you're held
physically responsible as well you know
we're audited every year to make sure
that we that we obey the laws of Caesar
and then we also make sure that we obey
the laws of God yes you you stop paying
someone because you don't like their
lifestyle choices uh they'll pull that
501c3 so fast uh that your head will
spin well again our time has slipped
away from us yeah allow me in closing to
wish you both Grace and peace we'll see
you again soon bye-bye and God
[Music]
bless